If there are some questions that probably
are going to be of interest to everybody,
we'll save those for the end.
With answers to questions and the questions
themselves, we will make them available in
the Q&A document that will be linked to our
webinar and courses page and on the FTP site,
in the materials directory.
That is given to you as a compressed URL.
I am going to turn this over to Rana Morris
and she will talk to about APIs.
Thank you for joining us today.
Today is a little different than our usual
NCBI Minutes.
It will be a little longer.
We will talk about APIs developed at NCBI.
This is an introduction to NCBI APIs for people
who are new to them.
And for those who are API savvy just to give
you an I an idea of the diversity and breadth
of APIs available at NCBI.
For those of you who are using APIs such as
the e-utilities you may not learn too much
in this talk but we do want to hear from you
and we are interested in if you are wanting
to learn more.
If you have a specific question about how
to use a particular API or problems with the
script, please send a message into the helpdesk
(info@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov) and we will work directly
with you to help you with your script.
After this webinar, we will send a survey
to ask everyone for feedback.
We are interested in the specific API topics
you want to learn more about.
And also what functionality or access to specific
data at NCBI you want to have added to our
existing repertoire of APIs.
If you have other ideas we would like to hear
from you.
For beginners, what is an API?
What can it do for you?
Just to give a quick set of definitions.
URLs which you know about our web addresses.
They are composed of two main components.
A protocol identifier like HTTP or HTTPS,
FTP, SFTP, and a resource name.
Such as the ncbi URL or blast URL.
Those will get you direct links to the servers.
APIs are URLs with specific syntaxes that
have been designed for developers to use within
their scripts or applications or programs,
to interact with servers across the Internet.
NCBI APIs have been developed to access, process,
and retrieve data from our backend servers.
We are also using our own services now.
PubChem as an example we are using our own
APIs but there are other commercial companies
and other people who are using APIs, including
EndNote, BioGPS, there is a Molecules app
for the iPad and more.
I am going to describe APIs for beginners.
As kind of an action based sentence with specific
grammatical parts.
I will show you how to do this in a minute
with our most popular API that so many people
are using.
What I will cover today are really four specific
APIs that we have.
There's a whole bunch more.
I want to show you where to find the information
on these and then I will show you where you
can keep up and find out more information
in general.
We will talk about EDirect which is really
not an API but uses APIs and it may be an
alternative if you don't want to write your
own scripts but you want to be able to process
information from our backend servers.
Our most popular API is virtually sitewide.
Almost all of our databases, our Entrez databases,
and it's called the Entrez Programming Utilities.
Sometimes called the EUtilities or EUtils.
This is a set of structured URL calls to access
our databases and I will show you examples
as to how to use these.
There are about 25 million EUtils calls that
are actually sent to our servers every day
from about 100,000 different IP addresses.
This is a little more than is hitting from
our front end servers.
We have a lot more people who use those.
About 4.2 million people use the web services
every day that are making these calls.
This is a popular resource.
Different types of things you can do and these
are a small set of examples.
You can search PubMed with the term and retrieve
the PubMed identifiers.
You can search MedGen with a SnoMedCT and
then link over to GTR for summary information
for the genetic tests related to that ID.
You can post a list of GeneID's and fetch
there full records, even post a PubChem compound
CID and see what the molecule looks like.
We have a lot of information about the EUtils
. I will show you a book and a bigger slide
to show you how to get the information to
use these things.
There are two YouTube videos on our YouTube
site one is only four minutes long it's a
quick introduction.
One is a full hour.
That will give you a lot of detail.
Those are the links there.
The key thing about the EUtils is the base
URL.
Any time you see eutils in the URL you will
notice that happens to be calling our EUtils
API.
This is the book of instructions to help you
figure out how to use the EUtilities.
As a matter of fact you have a table of contents
on the right-hand side this is the bookshelf.
There's an introduction and it has a whole
description of all the different EUtilities,
and even some sample applications and scripts
to show you as examples how to use them.
The key to using any API is not only to know
which server to hit, but also where to operate.
In our case we think of it as a noun in a
sentence as where to operate and what kind
of database or what kind of data you want
to get.
This is an example from our gquery page that
shows you all the different databases that
we have at NCBI.
It is a wide diversity of different types
of data.
And EUtilities works pretty much in all of
the Entrez databases.
Here is the base URL with your EUtils.
That's what you want to use for every call
for an API involving the EUtilities.
You need to add a couple of things to your
sentences.
Need to have verbs that tell you what you
want to do and then nouns.
So as an example, in that red box you can
put a verb which - - these are examples of
some of the calls you can make to tell the
EUtilities what to do.
You can do a search you could post you could
or create a summary or grab a fetch a record
or link between databases.
Then you need a noun to tell you what are
you starting off with?
I have a text query I want to perform in esearch
with.
I have a set of IDs that I want to post or
grab the esummaries from or I want to fetch
the whole record or i want to link from one
set of IDs to a database and get something
back on the other end.
These are the things that you get on the other
end.
One of these particular verbs.
Here's an example.
Let's say you want to get a summary of information
about a gene.
You know the Gene ID which happens to be 3269.
That happens to be the ID for the human histamine
receptor H1.
Here's how to structure one of the EUtilities
APIs.
You have your base URL call which will identify
the server you want to go to , eutils.
You have a verb.
In this case an essummary, get me the E summary
for this particular record.
I want to go in this particular database.
I want to use this particular term.
You can also specify what the format is.
Right now we will go with the default.
We will show you what that is in a moment.
It's hard to see, but this is, if you copy
paste the URL and put it into a web browser,
you get back a structured list here in XML
which happens to be the default that shows
you what you get back which is the esummary
in XML format for the histamine H1 from the
Gene database.
Another example could be trying to find PubMed
record IDs for this Gene ID.
In the Gene database we are able to link directly
from the gene to records in PubMed that have
been identified as referring to this particular
gene.
I'm only showing you the first half, the back
half of the API call.
You would still use the same base call all
the way up here through eutils in blue, and
instead of esummary you would use elink and
you would want to link from one database,
Gene, to another one, PubMed.
We will start off with our ID again 3269.
This is what it looks like.
Again it's in XML which is the standard format.
We can change the format and we will show
you that.
We actually - - starting off from Gene to
the DB PubMed, here's your id, 3269, and then
these are different PubMed identifiers that
correspond to that gene record.
I showed you things in XML and I showed you
e-summaries.
We can change the format of how we get things
back.
Maybe don't like XML you want a different
format.
You can do that in the utilities by using
the retype parameter and specify what you
want to return it as.
So this is what it looks like.
Here as a e-summary from PubMed this happens
to be one of the IDs we saw before.
You will see over here in the screen below,
this long XML with all the authors and the
title and the information that is in the summary
about that particular ID.
If you add retype at the end, in orange here,
and you say medline you will get it back in
that format.
You librarians who happen to be on the line
might be very familiar with that.
Or in this particular case we are doing and
E fetch and that's getting the entire record
which includes the abstract.
You won't have that in your summary but you
can get that back in XML.
You can specify it or if you don't put the
Rettype and you will automatically get that
back in XML.
These EUtils call are useful not just individually
but useful for eutils pipelines.
You can start off with one eutils call and
daisy chain it to another and another to do
something useful.
Here is an example of what you can do.
Let's say you start off with the disease hereditary
hemochromatosis which happens to have a specific
Snomed CT ID.
You want to do a search in our disease database
MedGen.
We will do an esearch in MedGen.
That will get us back a set of MedGen id's.
Let's say you want to find not just the MedGen
ID's but you want to find it in the genetic
testing registry to find out if there are
tests for hereditary hemochromatosis.
What you can do then is actually take those
MedGen IDs and use elink to go from MedGen
into GTR or the genetic testing registry.
That will get you back a bunch of GTR or genetic
testing registry identifiers.
And then, the id's are nice but you'd like
to get human readable information so that
you can pull the esummary of the GTR IDs and
then in the summary information you will be
able to get who is giving the test and who
to contact.
So you can make three EUtilities calls and
start out with one input and get something
hopefully very useful out of it.
The book on the bookshelf for the Entrez programming
utilities has lots of examples.
They have a lot of examples of these EUtilities
calls.
The important thing to know is that you can
hit our servers and we would love you to use
this.
It helps us and helps the users.
We do need you to respect all the different
other people who are accessing the service.
We have some usage guidelines we want you
to use.
We want you to limit the URL request to less
than three calls per second.
If you have a large job let's say you have
a whole huge list of IDs we want you to limit
them to week days, weekends, or weekday nights
Easter Standar Time, that way more and more
people can access the servers without too
much traffic.
We have to warn you that if you do not comply
with this policy, you could be blocked until
we can talk with you.
And try to help you resolve the issue.
Most of the time, it's just that one tweak
fixes the problem.
If we don't know what that is, we can help
you.
One thing you can currently do is send a email
to our eutilities email address letting us
know what your tool and addresses are and
include that in your EUtilities call.
If there are problems with the script we have
an email address.
We will try to contact you before we block
you.
If you don't use that information or put it
in there and we don't have any idea who to
contact.
we'll try to find the closest IP address we
can to the one that sending the script and
block it.
Coming up, anticipated late March/April 2018,
we will be initiating a brand-new EUtilities
API registration system that will allow you
to actually register your own email address
and your API.
We will give you an API key that you can use
in all your URL calls.
That will help us manage our services and
we'll give you a bonus for doing it.
We will allow you to make call rates faster
than three per second.
Hopefully it will help you out as well.
We will have more and more information as
we get closer to that date about how to access
it and register and what you need to do.
There are lots of other API tools at NCBI.
One of the ones that many people haven't heard
about is one of the suite of PubMed Central
tools that have been developed to help people
who are using our PMC database.
There's one in particular called the ID converter
which I think might be helpful.
If you are submitting a manuscript because
you have NIH funding or even those from PMC
Canada or you are submitting things to PMC
in Europe, you may want to take your manuscript
ID and find out what the final PMC id is.
You can correlate PMC IDs with PM IDs or even
the digital object identifiers, the DOI.
This works specifically for articles listed
in PMC.
Not everything in PubMed will work only if
they have an article in PMC.
Examples of things you can do.
Let's say you have a NIHMS ID because you
submitted it in your grant processing.
You can find the PMCID or the PMID for that.
You can correlate PMIDs with PMCIDs that have
free full text articles and find DOIs.
There is a base URL for the PMCID converter
as well.
You will notice it doesn't have EUtils in
it.
It actually has PMC as the database and idconv
because it's the converter.
That's the beginning of all of the URL calls
you will use for the particular API.
There is a PMC developer resources page.
Here is the URL.
It's /pmc/tools/developers.
There is all sorts of different APIs they've
developed with the PubMed central group.
The ID converter will get you to a page that
tells you how to use the information.
I have a number of different examples.
Very similar to the EUtilities calls.
The difference is the base URL is different
and then again the parameters are slightly
different.
You can find your information back in regular
XML but other formats as well, things like
json or even csv.
I am not going to go through examples.
But on the ftp site, if you look for the URL,
that go.usa.gov, I actually have all of these
things worked out with screenshots.
You can take a look.
If you copy paste them directly into a browser
you can see what it looks like.
Usage guidelines.
The PMC crew would like you to know that you
can add a lot of identifiers in each individual
request, but don't mix the types of IDs the
API will not work.
In other words if you are starting off with
NIHMS IDs just stick a bunch of them in one
row.
Do not mix a NIHMS with a PubMed or a DOI.
You can use up to 200 IDs . You could just
daisychain those together with commas.
If you are a larger number, split it up so
you have less than 200 per call.
If you have a really large set there's actually
a file in the FTP site you may want to take
a look at.
It does a direct correlation of PMC IDs with
NIHMS with PubMed with DOI.
Another API at NCBI and this is our second
most popular is BLAST.
They call it a BLAST URL API.
It will allow you to run sequence similarity
searches remotely on our servers.
It's a three-step process.
You have to do all three otherwise you won't
get your results.
You submit the job to the server and tell
them what you want them to do.
Then you have to let the BLAST calculations
process.
You want to check the information to see if
the job is done and when it is done you can
retrieve the information.
There's lots of things you can do you can
search for an identical or near identical
sequence to find out more about it.
You can look for potential homologues you
can find where a sequence matches on the genome.
You can do a lot of things with BLAST.
The BLAST URL API base here has BLAST in it
and then blast.cgi.
It will identify a blast API call as one different
from a PubMed central ID convertor.
There's lots of information on BLAST.
On the home page there's a help link and if
you click on it you can get lots of information
about BLAST in general.
On the right-hand side is Developer information
which gets you to a page that will help you
use the developer tools including the BLAST
REST interfaces.
Clicking on one of the documentation links,
will take you over to a GitHub page.
That page gives you all the information about
the URL API and also see more information.
All the different parameters to customize
your BLAST searches are listed on that page
as well.
Just like the PMC ID converter I will not
go through this specific example.
The slides are available on the FTP site which
steps through each of the processes.
Submitting a query and in this particular
case we will try to find sequences that are
similar to the human acetylcholinesteras in
the PDB database which happens to be a structure
database.
We will use the blastp program and again the
database is PDB.
The most important point I want to make is
the usage guidelines for our BLAST APIs.
You can submit calls and we would like you
because of the intense nature of the calculations
to keep the calls three seconds apart for
the initiation of each of the searches.
Probably more important than anything else
is for the second step, where you have to
check on the progress of your BLAST search
with the RID or request identifier.
You need to let the BLAST search perform its
calculations before you check.
Please consider a delay between step one and
step two for at least one minute to let the
BLAST search do its thing.
After you search, you are looking for a status
equals Ready to let you know the calculation
is done.
If that is not there, you can check again
and we request you put a 30 second spacer
in between each subsequent check.
Once the ready status exists you can get your
results.
There are a lot of different formats you can
get them in from text XML even to a really
cool tabular format.
Please limit your BLAST searches to less than
100 more per day.
If you need to do more we've created a service
called blast in the cloud which you can find
on the GitHub page.
You can use the script against the BLAST servers
in the cloud or use BLAST yourself.
Our third API want to hit is specifically
designed for our chemical database, PubChem,
and they call the PubChem API, PUG REST.
It's very restful and there are two main types
of PUG REST calls.
One of them and you can see the base URL on
right-hand side of the page they start off
with pubchem that's how you know they are
PubChem APIs.
One of them says pug_view and one is just
pug.
I will show you the difference in just a second.
Different examples you can do is you can search
for chemical synonyms and let's say you have
propanol you want to know what all the different
names are.
Like tamoxifen or estrogen.
You can find properties for chemicals things
like molecular weight.
You could get sections of PubChem compound
records.
Let's see you have tamoxifen and you want
to know what the pharmicology information
is.
You can pull that down out of the record.
You can see the two dimensional structure
for a chemical with a single URL cal.
There's a lot of information and a lot of
examples in the PUG REST help documentation.
How to find that.
From the PubChem homepage under the services
tab, there's a link to PUG REST which has
a lot of text information . It's a very long
document, but here's the beginning of the
table of contents that will help you step
through the process of creating these URLs.
There's a number of different URLs.
Again the examples here are worked out in
the PowerPoint and PDF that is on the FTP
site.
The pug view URL which is listed here as pug_view/data
will allow you to pull out whole sections
of the PubChem compound records.
Use the headings from the table of contents
to get all the synonyms or compound identifiers
for 3100 which happens to be diphenhydramine
or Benadryl.
You can also look for a different heading.
MeSH pharmacological classifications.
This is a helpful section to talk about the
pharmacological actions that this particular
chemical diphenhydramine has.
Notice we have JSON on here.
They provide formats of json and xml and others.
The caveat for the pug_view which will pull
out individual sections of the PubChem compound
record is it only works with the IDs or compound
identifiers in other words this number 3100.
How do you find the compound identifiers?
Let's say you have the name Benadryl and you
want to look something up.
You can use the EUtilities, remember the eutils
work with virtually all of our databases,
or you can use the other type of PUG REST
API, that's called PUB, which will allow you
to do more than see the compound identifiers.
As an example here it says just /rest/pug
and not pug view.
Compound which is the name of the database,
name, and Benadryl.
Name is the type of input you have here, Benadryl;
you can get back the CID's in the text information.
You can get lots of information including
concatenated stuff as well as pictures.
The usage guidelines.
Please keep them less than five requests per
second.
If you want large sets of information the
PubChem FTP site has a lot on there.
Finally I want to introduce you quickly to
an alternative.
For people who want the data but they don't
want to do the scripting, you can use a thing
called Entrez or E-direct.
It's not an API of itself it's a suite of
applications that use the Entrez utilities.
Lots of information about how to use the E-direct
tools are not only on the bookshelf and we
happen to have an E-direct cookbook that will
allow you to see examples.
We also have training programs webinars and
courses.
They are hyperlinks you can get to as well
as four-part YouTube videos put out by our
PubMed customer service group.
As a matter of fact we are teaching courses
on it.
Peter Cooper will be teaching a course in
E-direct on 18 September at the NIH.
If you happen to be in Bethesda or the DC
Metro area.
The big thing about E-direct os that you use
line commands.
You don't have to write scripts.
You can customize what you get back.
It's not just searching for what is in the
database and retrieving it but you are able
to parse it and reformat it and download it.
How to find information about E-direct it's
actually in the Entrez programming utilites
book that you saw before.
It's a whole chapter.
And then the Entrez Direct cookbook on GitHub
has lots of examples.
We are accumulating more, in part with Ben
Busby's hackathon program.
Just to let you know we have a number of other
APIs, the variation services or the sequence
position deletion insertion, SPDI.
They will allow you to play with the different
variation servers we have here at NCBI.
The genome remapping service is similar to
the Entrez Direct in that it's a Perl script
to download that allows you to help coordinate
mapping on one genomic assembly to another.
That is a lot of information.
How do I keep up with it?
From our NCBI homesite we have a thing called
Develop.
This will take you to a developers site to
give you more information than you probably
ever need about our tools including our APIs
listed there.
That gives you a whole page.
We will be updating this set of APIs very
shortly to add more and more.
I am wrapping up.
As you may imagine we have lots of resources
here at the NCBI.
Also at the national Library of medicine.
Where they have additional APIs you might
be interested in.
Here's the URL where you can find out more
about all the APIs that the national Library
of medicine provides.
We will be cataloguing not just these APIs
but even more that we have and we will be
putting them on that Develop page that you
just saw.
There are webinars like this and courses like
peters to help.
You can get those on the NCBI Learn site for
more information.
We want to introduce you to the concept of
hackathons, where scripters may use APIs to
create tools.
Ben Busby is coordinating one in Pittsburg
at the end of September that will enlist use
of APIs in order to help create really cool
tools.
There's lots of information I covered.
These are the base URLs for all the documentation
for each individual API I talked about.
We have a NCBI insights blog were a lot of
things are posted about APIs and other services
at NCBI and of course the YouTube website.
We have an email address for help on all the
resources including the APIs that you may
be using and the FTP site for lots of data.
We encourage you to send messages in, so we
can help you learn to use the APIs effectively.
Thank you very much for listening.
All the information will be on the FTP site.
We look forward to hearing from you on the
survey as well to help guide us in providing
more and better information about what we
have at NCBI.
Thank you.
[Peter Cooper] Thank you Rana.
I don't think we have a lot of time for questions.
I have answered most of the ones that were
straightforward in the questions pod.
There is one question here I don't think,
we may not know the answer.
I thought I would throw it out there to Rana.
Someone asked about the things that work for
PMC will they work for the NASA, and NIST
and DHS repositories on PMC.
I'm not familiar with that.
[Rana] I will check on that with the PMC folks.
From what I understand, if these things happen
to be at NCBI in the PMC database they should
work.
If there are other sources, I can't guarentee
it, we will ask the question and we will add
it to that Q&A document so you can find that
information as well.
[Peter] Thanks, Rana.
There're been a few question.
Most of them are very specific and straightforward.
I will make sure we have those in the Q&A
document.
People were asking about the slides and recordings.
All the things are available on the materials
directory.
Also it's in the questions module.
Write to us if you have question.
You can write to webinars@NCBI.nlm.nih.gov.
For general questions please write to info@NCBI.NLM.NIH.gov.
Thank you for coming.